hello reject nation up just slightly
there we go hello reject nation I'm Greg
Alba like time
Calvin Rutter hey cat I hear on Friday
you are gonna be on the FNX Channel I am
gonna be on the FNX chain that's a TV
channel Wow not a YouTube thing no
naughty it's a TV thing the actual teeth
like click turn it on there it is 9 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time this Friday it's
Friday March 23rd on the pepper and X
channel you know what let's put a link
in the description box well so now if
you all can be familiar with the FNX
channel is and check your listings to
make sure you have it you might not have
it because I have only heard of FNX
today but it's a channel it's a channel
cat Alvarado is on it you know I think
we should promote it yeah let's promote
it maybe some other video maybe maybe
some other video we'll talk about the
FNX Channel this Friday at 9:00 9:00
p.m. at Alvarado hey Jack you like
comedy don't you you like the Conan
O'Brien
Conan isn't he the most handsome redhead
in the whole wide world yes
do you like Dwayne Johnson oh my gosh is
he not the most handsome person of
Samoan really no it's new movie coming
out called rampage which is like this
crazy monster fest movie another crazy
Rock action movie right and there's a
remote video from Conan Conan becomes
Dwayne Johnson's
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
action rolls you were born to be an
action star
you really were - check this out this is
a picture of you I think this is you at
15 years old at 15
[Laughter]
I'll be honest with you
Duane your big guy okay well no your big
guy you're tall
where's that mean it means you're tall
it means you're tall you've been blessed
with height don't be afraid to check it
out what they call pranks you know put
your hand on that okay put your hand on
them what are you feeling I feel a
breast
let's say you weren't Dwayne the rock
Johnson your side okay would you be all
worried be honest to be honest with you
I I would think this guy
that's the movie everybody wants to see
you
that's a great Photoshop what I'd like
to do is I'd like to train to be your
son in your body double Wow this way I
can look just like you and know God
that's right you know when you think
people are going to take money to see
Dwayne the rock Johnson in a movie I
would do that don't do that yeah
I just both great body double stunt
double first is to become you ran page
lab great chaos for your life you think
that makes one show okay because I know
that you question my physicality yeah
but that was your first mistake you
don't get a second chance
[Laughter]
well they would but probably with a
little bit more confidence well that was
your first mistake and you don't get a
second chance next for your first
mistake you don't get a second chance
you made a mistake you're the first time
mistakes you do not and I stress do not
get a second chance
he's really try not to laugh right there
right there okay
and where were you exactly cuz I wanna I
don't want anyone to see where you it
was about right this cool
did we just caught his butt crack okay
I thought that it was supposed to be a
launch right but this was more like a it
was more like a like a roll so what you
saying one I wanted to get how did you
feel
I guess I think we should also do it
again
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah George again crabs you yes cut okay
take out the star his identical twin
steps in and I am the action let's do
this okay and action
bring out that okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and that's why Conan is possibly my
favorite talk show host yeah he's pretty
awesome it's funny because I don't
really find his interviews anymore that
hilarious but whenever he does he's like
remotes with celebrities or whatever's
out on the street nothing makes me laugh
harder than this so good in the rock man
he is great with the improv
stuff like this one like oh this is why
he does so well in these giant comedies
- he was able to just roll with that he
felt every moment I keep knew how to
play off of every moment and when they
change it up then you had a work off
Conan not trying to steal the show it
was like yeah it was really a compliment
complementarity great job complimenting
Conan's style like he's a really good
straight man like Conan just silly goofy
yeah and the rock just he's just like
serious and just like what you're just
dumb I've known Tim probably teach you
like yes and for everything but he knew
when to like change it up and how to
proper and whenever he did like any form
of denial Conan knew how to work off
that really well I could watch a movie
with these two actually yeah like a
buddy cop yeah that's like weird buddy
cop bill yeah or watch a movie where
Dwayne Johnson's playing a satire
version of himself
and he has experience with wrestling
improvising in front of a crowd and
whatever scene this satire version of
like an egotistical version of doing
Johnson okay great you see what's that
movie stepdads okay here we go
instead of will ferrell and the other
guy we would have Conan and the rug I
could see that as an actual film this is
pretty funny this was such a delight to
watch and mana Kona is such a trooper no
one was like whoo-hooing or clapping
when he was throwing himself across the
table but that's actual stop work that
Conan was doing right there he could
have actually injured himself doing that
if he did it wrong I guess especially
cuz he's tall like tall people get
injured so easily we think they're like
whoa unprofessionalism
was that you oh now we can't use any of
this video cuz I don't believe in
editing jump cut so we were saying just
now all that all that stunt work was
real stunt work like he could have
gotten hurt right yeah
conclusion of the video Conan in the
rock should make a movie together
that's all we're hoping for only one
where they're both my dad ah both your
dad yeah there might like that that's
your dream fantasy right there no I
don't want my dad I mean my your actual
dad no but like a fantasy you know
you're in a movie I don't want incest to
be a thing it's not it why that's so you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell they get
notified every time a video of ours is
up cat off rato is of course in social
media links in the description box
channel this Friday what's that date
23rd March 23rd 9 p.m. you catch it
there on your television station
performing comedy please tune in and
then call FNX and let the program know
that you found out about their channel
through the real rejects real reject cuz
they're the number one TV channel I
wanna get on